-Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you for that...
for that wonderful welcome.
That applause actually lasted
longer than Anthony Scaramucci.
Absolutely...
Welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
I'm your host,
Jimmy Fallon, everybody.
Well, people are still talking
about Anthony Scaramucci
getting fired.
He lasted just six days,
making him the shortest-serving
White House Communications
Director ever.
But don't feel bad.
Publishers have offered him
a lot of money
to write a tell-all pamphlet
about the experience.
[ Laughter ]
Three pages.
[ Laughs ]
Three pages,
double-spaced, yeah.
-24-point font.
-He only lasted six days.
I mean, there were
White House fence jumpers
who lasted longer than that.
-Come on!
-Six days is nothing.
-Ohh!
-But get this.
Trump is apparently looking
for a less prominent position
for Scaramucci
that wouldn't require him
to be seen very often.
Scaramucci said,
"You want me to be First Lady?"
And you go, "No, no,
that's not what I mean by that.
Where's Melania? Melania!
She's just -- She's late.
She's arriving late."
But it's been a rough week
for Scaramucci.
In fact, I saw that in
the latest alumni directory
for Harvard Law School, he was
mistakenly listed as dead.
It's nothing personal.
That's just what happens
in Harvard
if you don't donate any money.
Yeah. They get...
But Anthony Scaramucci joined
a long list of officials
that President Trump has fired.
That might explain
this commercial that I just saw.
Watch this.
-Are you looking for work?
-Yes.
-Unsure about your future?
-Or maybe you have a job,
but you're worried you could be
let go at any moment?
-Absolutely.
-Then forget about LinkedIn
and join KickedOut,
the only jobs website
made for people
who've been fired from
the Trump administration.
-Fantastic.
-KickedOut knows exactly
how to get you
that amazing new job.
We take your résumé
and delete anything that says
you've worked for Donald Trump.
-Isn't that wonderful?
-KickedOut.
Sorry. We can't help you get on
"Dancing with the Stars."
-KickedOut.
-KickedOut is the new LinkedIn.
-It's called KickedOut.
[ Applause ]
-Actually, earlier today,
the White House announced
Scaramucci's replacement,
and we have him right now
via satellite from Washington.
Please welcome Donald Trump's
new communications director,
Andrew Moore.
Thank you
for being here, Andrew.
-Thank you.
Thank you, Jimmy.
I'm excited for the challenges
of being
communications director,
and I'm confident
that I'll be fully capable
of seamlessly transitioning
into the new role.
-Now, Andrew,
what experience do you have
that qualifies you to take on
this very important role
in the White House?
-That's a good question, Jimmy.
For the past eight years,
I've been fighting for the --
-Wait. I'm so -- I'm so sorry.
I'm not sure
what's going on here.
What -- What happened to Andrew?
-Oh, he was fired.
[ Laughter ]
-Just now?
-Yep. Check Trump's twitter.
Anyway, I'm taking over the job.
-Oh.
Well, who -- who are you?
-My name is Jerome Kennard.
-All right, well, Mr. Kennard,
I'm not quite sure
where to begin,
but are you nervous
about taking over
the communications director
position?
-A little nervous, yeah.
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
W-Who are you?
-I'm the new White House
communications director,
Bob Wellington.
Uh, Jerome was fired.
-You're the new White House
communications director?
-That's right, Jimmy.
Matt Grady. Nice to meet you.
-Now, this -- Wait.
Another -- Another new
communications director?
That's the fourth
new communications director
in one minute.
How is that possible?
-Heh. I know.
It's a little crazy.
-Wait. You again? Andrew?
They -- They rehired you?
-Oh, no.
I just left my mug here.
It was the only thing
I had enough time to
put on my desk, so...
-Well, then, who is
the new communications director
at the White House?
-It's me, Jimmy.
I'll just do it myself.
-Donald Trump, you're your own
new communications director?
-Yes. Oh.
No, I guess not anymore.
I'm looking at my Twitter
account. I just fired me.
-All right. That's enough.
Thank you very much.
Andrew Moore, Jerome Kennard,
Bob Wellington,
Matt Grady, and Donald Trump,
everyone.
Confusing. Confusing.
Well, yesterday was White House
chief of staff John Kelly's
first day on the job.
But it got awkward
when he showed up and said,
"Why are you writing my name on
the door in dry-erase marker?"
Wait. That's not a good sign.
-That's not good.
-No.
-But it's crazy.
As of today, 12 top government
or White House officials
have been fired or resigned
since Trump took office.
Yeah.
And Trump was like,
"Just five more eliminations
until I announce the winner."
That's not how this works!
It's not a reality show.
What are you doing?
The other big story
that people are talking about
is that Trump dictated
Don Jr.'s misleading statement
about meeting with
a Russian lawyer last year,
which puts the president
in legal jeopardy.
When Trump heard
that he was in jeopardy,
he said,
"I'd rather play Family Feud.
Show me collusion!"
Ber!
Here's a local story.
Utility workers
here in New York City
retrieved a woman's wedding ring
that she dropped down a sewer...
while the rat handing it back
was like, "Always a bridesmaid.
[Inhales sharply]
Congratulations."
[ Applause ]
Well, last night, was
the "Men Tell All" episode
of "The Bachelorette,"
where the guys who were
eliminated from the show
talked about their experiences.
The fans love it,
and I think it might have
inspired another show, too.
Check this out.
-Tonight on ABC, tune in
for a very special event,
"The White House Men Tell All."
Watch Reince talk about having
his heart broken by Donald.
-Well, it's disappointing, but
I don't think it's over yet.
-See Sean try to find the words
to describe saying goodbye.
-I think -- Let's -- Let's --
I think at some point,
you know, he's -- he's --
-And Anthony reveals the very
last thing he said to Donald.
-[Bleep] Thank you.
-That's all tonight on
"The White House Men Tell All."
-"The White House Men Tell All."
And finally,
this is going viral.
The other day
on a Southwest flight,
a little boy greeted everyone
with a fist bump
on his way to his seat.
It's pretty cute.
Check this out.
-He wants to fist-bump you.
-Let's do it.
[ Imitates explosion ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And this is nice.
It only delayed the flight
for two hours.
[ Applause ]
"Get your kid in the seat!"
He was so good at using his fist
that he was just hired
by United Airlines.
There you go, guys.
We have a great show tonight.